les autochtones devrait-il arrêter la
pêche et la chasse pour protéger les
espèces en danger alors pour répondre à
ta question brigitte je dois en premier
dire que c'est une question qui est très
sensible présentement parce qu'on sait
que une perte de biodiversité qui
s'accélère en plus avec les changements
climatiques mais malheureusement à
travers ça il ya aussi un mythe
énormément de biaiser et qui la vie dure
comme quoi les premières nations pour
partir de la raison pour laquelle cette
biodiversité leur est en train de
disparaître
ne serait ce que parce qu'on pratique la
chasse traditionnelle où la pêche
traditionnelle on est vu comme ceux qui
aident à agir et à la tombée de la
population des caribous par exemple ou
du saumon
mais je tiens à dire une chose qui est
extrêmement importante et d'ailleurs qui
de plus en plus reconnu dans les cercles
scientifiques à l'onu un peu partout les
premières nations les peuples
autochtones à travers la planète ceux
qui utilisent le territoire qui en
bénéficient qui pêche qui chasse qui
cueille sont les meilleures personnes
pour pouvoir gérer le territoire
et pourquoi mais parce qu'on est
présents sur le territoire on dépend du
territoire si le territoire s'effondre
si les populations de caribous
s'effondre qui va en souffrir le plus
bien ce sont les populations autochtones
ceux qui en souffrent le moins ce sont
ceux qui vont des fois demandé à ce
qu'on fasse des aires de protection
traditionnel si on empêche le passage
humain où la pratique traditionnelle
autochtone sur le territoire parce qu'on
se dit moyen d'interaction humaine est
plus une chance que les populations se
remettre justement de ces effondrements
là mais justement loin des yeux loin du
coeur et on le voit plus on protège mais
moins on est présent des gens qui vont
envoyer leurs 20 $ pour les bélougas par
exemple ou bien pour les phoques ne
seront pas nécessairement ceux qui vont
être sur le territoire à voir qu'est ce
qui se passe dans la population il les
impacts réels des changements
climatiques sur ces populations là
cependant il faut pas oublier qu'une
chasse traditionnelle une pêche
traditionnelle une cueillette
traditionnels se fait vraiment dans une
idée de conservation et de pérennité du
territoire donc nous on en est des
gardiens on a cette responsabilité là
depuis des milliers d'années
donc quand on chasse qu'on pêche on sait
qu'on doit donner du temps à une
population pour ça
ce repli ne se remettre justement d'une
chanson c'est comment ne pas chasser de
la même manière partout au même endroit
donc je comprends que ces savoirs
ancestraux leçon à la base une raison
pour laquelle on a pu être pendant des
milliers d'années sur le territoire avec
la population des animaux et des
poissons qui continuait de pouvoir nous
permettre de survivre sur ce territoire
là et malheureusement
eh bien ce sont d'autres choses sont de
mettre un coup de poing beaucoup plus
difficile sur les populations animaux
animal suffisamment c'est vraiment les
changements climatiques la pollution la
présence humaine là
l'extractivisme les barrages
hydroélectriques la coupe en forêt quand
on fait de ces pratiques abusives sans
toucher directement l'animal c'est là
que le mal se fait le plus grand et
quand on fait une chasse qu'on fait une
pêche traditionnelle et bien on s'assure
toujours de pouvoir revenir l'année
d'après et c'est comme ça qu'on fait
pendant des milliers d'années partie du
territoire et qu'on est encore
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir vous parler et
répondre à vos questions à paroles
autochtone en espérant que vous allez
partager la chronique en espérant vous à
nous envoyer d'autres questions on vous
souhaite une belle semaine à part à
l'automne